Nguyen Huy Một Tháng Năm, Năm Háng Nèng không chăm thành bùi sấu, phòng cán sách hình dự công an thành phố cường thời cho biết,
vừa bất dữ đứa từng hồ báo khăn, xin Năm Háng Nèng là năm để điều tra về hành vi giết người.
Lên quan vua an mạnh đặt việc nhiên trọng, sĩ ra tại một nhà trò trên đi bàn phường hương phố thành phố cường thời.
Chứ đó, khoảng 18 giờ ngay mùi tháng Năm, chứ như trò tại khu vực phút thắng phát hiện phòng trò cho thành thời của Bùi Là,
nên liên hệ yêu cầu quanh về chiếm trà.
Tuy nhiên, chứ không thể liên là được với khăn đến đạn sáng 11 tháng Năm,
chứ như công những người xung quan phát phòng thì phát hiện một thị thể nữ đang trung quá trình phân quyền nạn,
nên trên báo công an.
Sất định đây là dù án đặt việc nhiêm trọng,
giám đốc công an thành phố đã chỉ đào phòng cảnh sách hình dự,
phối học các đường về nghiệp dụ khấn trường phòng tỏa hình trường,
khám nghiệm tử thi, truy sẽ đối tình gây an.
Quên điều tra, lực lượng công an sách định hồ báo khăn,
là nhi phạm trực tiếp liên quan vụ an và nhân chống tổ chức truy bắt,
tại thúc quan công an, khăn khai nhận trong quên trình trung sống như vậy trong với chỉ đây,
cá hai thường suyên sĩ đà mồ thống liên quan chuyện tình bạch và sinh hoàn,
tối 1 tháng Năm, sau khi cải nhau lời dụng lúc nạn nhân đất ngủ,
khăn đáng ra tài sách hài, thời điểm sĩ đà vùa việc nạn nhân đặt măng thài.
Đáng chứ ý, sau khi gây an, đối tưởng không đời khó hình trường ngay,
mà tiếp tục ở lại phòng tròn qua điểm cùng thi thể nạn nhân.
Những ngày sau đó, khăn nhiều lần quay trở lại căng phòng,
nơi sĩ đà vùa an, thầm chỉ tịt tục mũ lại qua điểm rồi mới rồi đi.
Đứng ngày sau tháng năm, đối tưởng mưu sang gia dầu hả mang dài hiền trường,
nhằm phi tăng giấu giết trước khi bỏ trống, đến sáng 1 mục tháng năm,
khi đáng chào đón khách tài khu dân cửa hồng loàn,
phương kế rằng thì khăn bị lực lượng trình sách phòng cảnh sách hình dự phát hiện bắt giữ,
khi hình phòng cảnh sách hình dựa công an thành phố cường thật,
đáng tịt tục điều trà, làm đỏ vùa an để sử lý thầy quy định pháp luật.